the president's raucous rally that you
saw right here on Fox just ended but you
wouldn't know it if you were watching
the mainstream media CNN they barely
covered it and conspiracy TV MSNBC
literally acted like it wasn't happening
now by the way of course we brought you
the rally including when the president
took Democrats the mainstream media to
task for the blatant hypocrisy over the
topic of immigration and one of the
reasons the media didn't cover it they
would have been called out for all of
their lies and the fact that they're
missing the biggest story in American
history
take a look Democrats don't care about
the impact of uncontrolled migration on
your communities your schools your
hospitals your jobs or your safety
Democrats put illegal immigrants before
they put American citizens we've already
started the wall we got 1.6 million the
wall has been started San Diego and lots
of different places and we go but boy
it's tough they want to do anything they
can to obstruct and to make sure it does
it happen but it's happening it's
happening for days the so-called members
of the press the destroyed Trump media
along with their friends in the
Democratic Party they have been in a
complete utter insane meltdown over
reports that children were being
separated from parents at the border
after being detained for crossing the
border illegally and I've said numerous
times this week no one ever wants to see
ever a kid separated from their parents
nobody wants to see that and earlier
today by the way the president has been
saying it all week the president
addressed this important issue and he
signed an executive order on doing their
damage and ensuring that illegal
immigrant families would be kept intact
by the way not his law he didn't pass it
Congress did another president signed it
but he fixed it take a look border
security will be equal if not greater
than previously so we're going to have
strong very strong borders but we're
going to keep the faith
together I didn't like the site or the
feeling of families being separated is a
problem that's gone on for many years as
you know through many administrations
and we're working very hard on
immigration it's been going on for 60
years 60 years nobody's taking care of
it nobody's had the political courage to
take care of it but we're going to take
care of it
so today the president undid the damage
Congress mandated and a previous
president sign now this order fills a
void vacated by Congress which has
totally dropped the ball when it comes
to both illegal immigration and legal
immigration now it's time for these lazy
obstructionist members of Congress to
step up and do their job and that's a
permanent solution fix our broken
immigration system and by the way if
we're going to do it let's do it right
if we're going to do it every bill any
bill needs to literally point out what
the president laid out and by the way go
back to a State of the Union address
secure the border build the wall the
problem is solved completely but it must
be completely funded and constructed and
the money well I don't trust these guys
get it upfront or No Deal and by the way
all the loopholes have got to be closed
that are used by criminals and
terrorists and enemies of this country
to ever enter the country and that
includes ending the visa lottery system
that includes ending catch-and-release
of illegal immigrants they'll never show
up to court
eliminating chain migration and then and
only then okay
the Democrats will win something too
they'll get their concessions on daca
and by the way the issue of child parent
separation will end forever something we
all say we want now the wall the lotto
system the Visa Lottery the end of catch
and release
they can't be talking points Congress
we're on to you we're watching you
we know you often lie in your talking
points and say one thing and it never
matches the fine print of the bill so
don't play these swamp games the
American people are now hip to your
little lies everything that we're
talking about needs to be
straightforward fully legislated and
enacted before any so-called daca
comprar
and now without a wall without border
enforcement well the problems that the
wall will never go away ever and sadly
that were you know we have to see all of
this through the prism of the midterm
elections everything you're seeing and
hearing from politicians and on these
fake news networks is about 2018 and
instead of passing legislation and
permanently fixing a big problem for the
country immigration well you've got many
Democrats they'd rather use this issue
to malign their political opponents that
never solve the problem
which fits perfectly into their brand of
identity politics they want the American
people to believe as they do every two
to four years Republicans a racist
they are sexist they're misogynist
xenophobic Islamophobic oh and they want
dirty air and water and they want to
kill your children and push your
grandmother over a cliff you hear those
lies every two and four years I played
the history of this so many times on
this show let me tell you the four
things that will happen by the way you
let Democrats win this election this
midterm and guess what's going to happen
this is their agenda number one they
want to impeach the president but
they're not going to tell you that
they've told every Democrat stop Maxine
Waters from saying impeach 45 they want
to do it but they won't tell you the
rest of their agenda they want open
borders they want to keep Obamacare and
just like Nancy Pelosi said they want to
roll back the tax cuts and steal those
crumbs back as she called them that the
president gave you in the tax cut bill
now earlier today the president exposed
what is the Democrats and the media's
blatant hypocrisy look at the video that
the president tweeted this is kind of
priceless take a look our immigration
system is both illegal immigration is
wrong plain and simple all of
not only in the state's most heavily
affected but in every place in this
country are rightly disturbed by the
large numbers of illegal aliens entering
our country the people who should be
here are those who come legally we have
to send a clear message just because
your child gets across the border that
doesn't mean the child gets to stay
oh so the president's and the Democrats
and the media they all play politics now
this president is vowed to fix the
immigration crisis in this country but
that didn't stop your media from going
completely off the rails insane listen
to a clip
NBC News reporter Lester Holt
interviewing a border patrol chief this
is outrageous what's this do you feel
like the bad guy in this to some extent
of me you are the instrument of a policy
that is obviously very controversial
right now a bad guy okay
Lester maybe you ought to get out of
that studio once in a while I've been to
the border 12 times all across Rio
Grande to San Diego I've been in the
drug warehouses I've been out when they
have arrested gang members and I've been
out in the drug warehouses
floor-to-ceiling all laid at the altar
of going to our kids Lester no wonder
why you're not number one in news
anymore you know what risking his life
yeah he's saving our kids from drugs and
those people that have bad intentions
that cross our open border and it gets
so much worse we are talking about a
full-on psychotic meltdown Holocaust
comparison some 22 of them slavery
comparisons well you have to see it to
believe it
check out this insanity Donald Trump
without a doubt is pure evil when you
played the tapes of what was heard a
couple of days ago in the Senators it's
horrific how can people do that that
hasn't happened in this country since
the time of slavery it hasn't happened
in the worlds at the time of the Nazis
and Donald Trump is right there with
them this is as if George Wallace had
won in 1968 the one through-line here
from Charlottesville to this issue is to
use your phrase a return to the most
disturbing elements of white supremacy
white male supremacy to be precise in
the national character overnight they've
now
criminals so people are trying to
understand what's happening here that's
what happened and you know what Elie
Wiesel may he rest in peace what he said
to me was he said you know the Nazis had
it perfectly correct they declared us an
illegal people that's how it began I
don't want little children ripped from
their parents arms I don't want them
marched off to quote showers you look at
this historically throughout American
history no matter the policy you're
talking about the separation of families
has always been something that speaks to
a level of inhumanity if you go back to
slavery by the way liberal Joe thinks
he's a conservative now if you can
believe it the reaction from some on the
left was even so much worse and so much
more disgusting now by the way I have to
warn you you have kids at home and I
hate ever saying turn off the channel or
just be careful what I'm about to show
you is not suitable for kids actor Peter
Fonda remember Hanoi Jane brother of him
tweeted about Donald Trump's DHS
secretary Kristen Nielsen Kristen
Nielsen is a lying bleep that she'd be
put in a cage and poked at by passer
buys the bleep should be pilloried in
Lafayette Square naked whipped by
passerby while being filmed for
posterity
and then he continued his randon this
time he turned his sick twisted ugly
vicious rage towards a twelve-year-old
kid
and by the way the president and Melania
Trump's son Barron we should rip Baron
Trump from his mother's arms and put him
in a cage with pedophiles and see if his
mother will stand up against the giant
bleep she is married to 90 million
people in the streets on the same
weekend in the country bleep okay
disgusting
now rightfully the first lady has every
right to protect her child and by the
way making terroristic threats against
the first family that's actually illegal
and she contacted the Secret Service
after that horrible tweet and Peter
Fonda then lately
perhaps sobered up deleted the tweet
later apologized saying in part he went
too far Peter too far well you could be
arrested for those words and frankly you
probably should be and here's the big
question of the day where's Nancy Pelosi
where's Elizabeth Warren where is the
champion of women Hillary Clinton where
is the outrage from the so called
compassionate left now Peters Fonda
Peter Fonda has come in so sick twisted
ugly demented and this is the insanity
coming from America's left and it's
there's a lot more look at Occupy Wall
Street promoting the murdering of ice
agents a member of an Tifa publishing a
list of 1,500 ice agents personal
information blasting it all over Twitter
they're going to get somebody killed
here this is not a game and then this
happened Donald Trump's DHS secretary
Kristen Nielsen who's following the laws
of Congress the laws of the land
literally is run out of a restaurant
last night by a group of leftist
protesters and we have the video watch
this left-wing insanity
[Music]
[Applause]
tens of thousands of people who come
here seeking asylum in the United States
we family separation Hillary Nancy
Pelosi Elizabeth Warren where are you
where's the me tube movement right now
tonight and the assault and the horrific
vicious things that are being said here
which brings us to a very important
point while the left the media literally
blows up over the Trump administration's
quote border tactics and they're obeying
the law they were very quiet when Obama
was their president the images were
about to show you take a look at this
children in cages sleeping in cages Oh
without their parents being there at all
many separated from their parents these
images they weren't taken after Donald
Trump was sworn into office no we
checked it out today the Daily Caller
printed a lot of these this was under
Barack Hussein Obama those pictures are
from the Obama administration and this
is how they detained illegal immigrants
in children in fact one such Obama era
policy actually detained minors without
their parents for months before
releasing them back to their home
countries remember it was President
Obama who prosecuted Oh nearly a half a
million illegal immigrants not Donald
Trump it was Obama who said he was
merely enforcing the laws laws that he
alone can't change and even if they
create great damage is compelled to
enforce the laws that Congress remember
he said all of this there are those in
the immigrants rights community who have
argued
passionately that we should simply
provide those who are illegally with
legal status or at least ignore the laws
on the books but I believe such an
indiscriminate approach would be both
unwise and unfair when I talk to
immigration advocates you know they wish
I could just bypass Congress and change
the law myself but that's not how
democracy works
believe me the idea of doing things on
my own is very tempting it I promise you
not not not just not just on immigration
reform but that's not how that's not how
our system works I'm the president
United States I'm not the Emperor of the
United States my job is to execute laws
that are passed my job to execute laws
that are passed I'm not the Emperor
that's exactly by the way the what
Donald Trump signed today let me be
blunt it'll last five minutes in a
courtroom before it's thrown out but at
least gives Congress time to do their
job I'm gonna have more on immigration
throughout the show tonight but first we
have something else to bring you that
the left of mainstream media is barely
touching and by the way one of the
biggest stories of our lifetime of
course the inspector general's report
totally vindicating the president's
decision not only to fire James Comey
but the IG corroborating everything we
have told you for months on this show
that the rest of the media never talked
about a two-tiered justice system a
rampant deep state bias an attempt to
literally create a soft COO in America
and prop up one candidate and destroy
the other candidate and you totally
watergate's a big deal and so much more
the mainstream media well they couldn't
care less look at the headline from News
Buster's today Monday CBS News totally
ignored the IG Horowitz first testimony
since the release of the IG report and
after two days of damning testimony from
the IG Michael Horowitz and so many new
revelations surrounding Peter struck
yesterday your friends at ABC so-called
News Georgie Stephanopoulos place NBC
News they avoided covering
struck at all the guy at the center of
the biggest corruption scandal in
American history of course we know one
of the most central figures of course
was the anti-trump FBI agent Peter
struck and I doubt he's going to testify
let's see if he chooses the right to
remain silent
now we showed you a detailed timeline
last night revealing what is rampant by
a shared between struck and his FBI
lawyer girlfriend leads a page including
clear instances where Peter struck the
head of both investigations was vowing
to work against struck and protected
Hillary from known felonies now remember
struck was also the lead agent in her
case that is the server investigation
and then immediately thereafter tap for
the lead role in the FBI's Trump Russia
investigation rendering by the way
illegitimate Muller's investigation he
cleared Hillary who committed literally
felonies one after another he vowed to
protect by the way and he worked against
Donald Trump and tried to destroy him
and that was all in the context of a
presidential election that sounds like a
big deal to me in a lot of different
ways oh and by the ways he's trying to
protect Hillary Clinton isn't it
interesting that it didn't work out
anyway as we scroll forward remember
struck was the lead agent and Hillary's
server investigation then tapped for the
lead here okay nobody in the media is
telling you any of this he clears one
person think about this in the context
of a presidential election in the
context of a presidential election you
know targeting Donald Trump who
eventually becomes president alright now
as we move on he will be called to
testify before Congress and by the way
the House Judiciary Committee Chairman
Bob Goodlatte
is reportedly ready to issue a subpoena
my prediction he ain't gonna talk just
the guest he will join us in a few
minutes of the upcoming showdown and of
course we also know struck is just the
tip of the FBI's high-level corruption
in fact the IG referred five agents for
investigation over rampant anti Trump
actions and struck spending testimony
could blow the lid off this deep state
house of cards which this is all
beginning to collapse people are going
to go to jail over this in other words
we're now created a deep state fiery
Squad and we're learning another wrinkle
in the deep state scandal it surrounds
Christopher Steele guess what
Christopher Steele the foreign spy who
the Clinton campaign paid for to produce
phony Russian lies against Trump well
that guy infamously known as the dossier
creator filled with those Russian lies
well steal by the way you know he was
welcome that Obama's State Department
just days before the 2016 election where
he allegedly briefed officials so what
did John Kerry know what did Obama know
when did they know it because you know
what what do they do with this phony
information and by the way when is the
media gonna start talking about all of
this and more importantly what is the
next shooter drop in all of this we have
so much more to come and what is the
biggest political scandal in your
lifetime and you at the forefront of
seeing it